pick up your phone and scroll and what
you see is obviously everybody's
highlight re social media is a beautiful
place to Showcase all the great things
you're doing that's what it's for and
that's amazing but what's not happening
is people aren't necessarily going on
and talking about the real stuff that's
happening behind the scenes so it's
really easy to think that you are so
alone in whatever mess is going on
because you're scrolling and you're
seeing all these fabulous things all of
these maybe fake vacations maybe fake
private jet situations maybe fake rented
cars and that's what we're surrounded
with all the time and so subconsciously
we start to build this belief that
whatever is going on in our life just
isn't good enough cuz it doesn't look
like that but we have to remember that
that's not real